[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute minute but let's do it in a way
that makes the snowflakes heads explode
let me be clear before this podcast
begins we are loud proud and do not give
a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him as
for Donald Trump yelling and screaming
the quiet part out
loud
verman he called you verman do you
remember when these [__]
snowflakes oh my God they were so
[__] upset you remember this when the
email lady was like they're a basket of
deplorables and they're like she called
us
deplorables and now they're like you
know what we are deplorables we're going
to be fascist as we want to be we we're
going to just lean into the farm fresh
fash we're going to go all full musini
on these jerk offs and that's what he
did I don't know if you know that I
don't know if you need to grab a history
book or not
MAA but when Donald Trump calls to send
people to camps and to exterminate
Vermin I don't know if you know this
there was a little uh book called my
struggle that talked about it musolini
talked about it a lot the the word
verman as referring to Jewish people
originated in melini's mouth that's why
this morning I have
[__] on the thumbnail of the YouTube
video [__] them what are you going to do
they might ban me for it or something
but I don't give it [__] he is an
[__] and again I you know I seriously
doubt that Donald Trump is coming up
with this stuff on his
own and I just don't quite believe
that you know what I mean I don't I just
I don't quite believe that Donald Trump
is coming up with this stuff you know he
said the blood poisoning thing when he
was talking about people crossing the
border months ago and again this is all
the leadup to uh project
I mean project 2025 says everything but
the word verman in
it but again this is 1930s Nazi Germany
fascist Italy style solutions that they
want and it's clear it's clear that Maga
wants these 1930 style
Solutions I mean you know a lot of
people are kind of freaking out
over
it I I don't know that that we should
freak out too heavy this morning again
on Mondays I gotta I gotta tune in to
Joe Scarboro and Morning
Joe so I know what not to take
seriously people are on there like oh
there's a 5050 shot that Joe Biden could
lose [__] out of here with this nonsense
as long as we the
people get out on our
feet and engage in democracy and go to
that battlefield of The Ballot
Box next year rather it be early voting
mailin voting rather it be absente
voting rather it be voting on Election
Day whichever way you decide to
vote you must do battle with the weapon
of your
ballot and I'm telling you I'm very
confident just as confident I'm
confident as now about next year's
election as I was about the election
last
Tuesday just as
confident nothing shaking me at all not
no [__] poll not no [__] dumb [__]
on MSNBC saying stupid [__] into a
microphone none of that
[__] Trump standing on stage being a God
damn Nazi and riling up his Nazi crowd
doesn't bother me a
bit I'm not shaking at all frankly I
hope you lean into it you [__]
fascist bastards do
it these [__] idiots out on the
Sunday shows this Sunday like Rona
McDaniel well I guess we just need a
National Abortion ban is what we need we
need we need to remage this sman issue
we need to we need to really make a
focus on on uh uh crime in the economy
Go For It Go For It Go for switching to
crime in the economy well don't do that
because Trump is head in the
polls get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense the country has made their
decision on Trump and maanga they just
haven't got the [__] message yet
this country does not want fascism they
don't want it it doesn't fit our society
it doesn't fit our style of of of
governance it just doesn't fit it is why
the Republicans in the house are gonna
have such a hard time keeping the
government open this week they're gonna
fail number one because they're they
don't know how to govern and they don't
want to govern they they clearly want
the government to shut
down they don't give a [__] about the
American people they don't give a [__]
about you and you people out there
waving the Trump flag and [__] they
definitely hate your [__] guts they
hate your [__] guts and you would be
the first Vermin that they send off on a
train to a goddamn gas chamber you dumb
sons of [__]
trust me on this just go look at up in a
[__] history book you dumb
bastards God damn these maglites piss me
off to be on no
end not enough [__] brain cells to
rub
together to even come up with a theory
that would work past the Earth is fles
for [__]
sake and you can't understand that your
[__] orange mango musolini Jesus
doesn't have have new meaning today I've
had that name for him for a long time
the orange mango musolini
Jesus those are all the things they love
right they've always loved this about
him
his aure towards authoritarians and
dictators he loves he loves murderous
[__] loves murderous dictators
they [__] they're [__] jerking off
in wet dreams about this project 2025
folks you talk about about a goddamn
Nazi takeover of our government and
dismantling everything that our
democracy has worked to build towards
Progressive policies like inclusion
Equity equality diversity in this
country which is the strength of our
liberal
democracy that is the foundational
strength of our
democracy is our diversity and our and
our tiptoe towards e equity and equality
we need to be running towards it but
it's you
know we're not there
yet but this [__] bonehead
standing on
stage talking about his struggle whoa
[__] and then you pair that with what sh
the [__] some of these other fascists
like Ronda santis is saying is just
shoot people just [__] kill them yeah
[__] due process of law and that what
the Nazis did that's what we'll do so
I'll go out on stage and say it Chris
Christie lying about women killing their
babies in the ninth month in New Jersey
get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense keep going you dumb sons of
[__] I can't even believe that
they're G to get even one vote next year
it's kind of pathetic and it really does
say a lot about our about our education
system that these [__] idiots would
even say this [__] out loud really
honestly and I'd hate to disparage our
public education system but mainly it's
in the red [__] states where they
have defunded it all these
years and made a mockery of public
education in rural
areas it's one reason why some people
think I'm so goddamn
dumb where do you think my [__]
edication comes from bunch of goddamn
Republicans controlling the State
education
budget
but the time ticks on doesn't
it we cannot relent we cannot turn away
from the fight that is in front of us we
must engage in our
democracy it is super
important and let me tell you something
when we really start to dig into the
project
2025 and I I know I know it feels like
like we should have already been doing
this but we had we had we had women's
rights to health care to protect in Ohio
and
Virginia we did that we as the
pro-democracy
Coalition we did
that we also made sure to to make to
make it
clear that
Democrats have a stronghold in Kentucky
even though it's considered a red
State and honestly in Mississippi Tate
Reeds had to had to had to cheat now I
don't know if the cheating caused him to
win but he was scared enough the
Republicans were terrified enough that
they would lose that they cheated they
made sure that black folks did not have
enough
ballot what do you want from
me but this
weekend and I'm going to show you the
clip and I got several different
versions of the
clip because I think it's
important of trump talking about verman
on
stage going full
fash in his campaign which again
shouldn't scare you
it should excite you to go tell all your
[__] all your farm fresh fash Uncle
Freds on
Facebook that hey look look dummy you
know how you keep calling liberals
fascist look look here look what this
is and as we unpack project 2025 because
that's the intention of it too this
project 2025 document it's like a
thousand pages
long
Carl Schmidt was the author of Nazis
project
2025 I don't know if you guys know
that Professor Carl
Schmidt is his
name go look it up you should probably
get
familiar because I'm G to get you
familiar with Carl Schmid and what his
goals were and how the Nazis and the
fascist in Europe Europe used it to
exterminate 6 million Jewish
people because they were
standing in the
way of them getting what they
wanted and I know a lot of people are
saying the project 2025 is scary
[__] and the scariest part isn't the
project 2025 stuff that's not the
scariest [__] okay
the fact that they're willing to say it
out loud and really the history of the
Heritage Foundation now Mighty librarian
at the library of democracy has been
doing a lot of work and there's going to
be videos coming out there's going to be
content coming out over there at the
library of democracy and I hope we have
some conversations over at the library
of democracy about the history of where
the project 2025 comes from and the
architect of the project 19 20s from
Carl Schmidt which has turned into the
project
2025 now the only reason why these
[__] boneheads are are doing the
project 2025 is because they know one
thing we stand in their
way the Democracy the government stands
in their
way of a total fascist
takeover that's that's what they know
and as long as we don't give them the
Reigns of government to undermine our
democracy we're g to be okay and I know
a lot of people have yelled and screamed
oh there's going to be another
Insurrection there's going to be another
January 6 and you know I get that a lot
in
comments let take it easy just take it
easy and the reason why is because we
did the right thing in 201 20 and we
handed the Reigns of government over to
syrius
people and Syria people had the Reigns
of
government in Washington DC it it's
going to be
okay they will do the correct things
like like the the people who were
serious did the correct things on
January
6th it will be a whole another ball game
if these [__] boneheads show up at
the
capital in
January of
2025 it'll be really [__]
stupid really [__] stupid I I don't I
don't think they understand exactly what
would happen apparently there's there's
some [__] around find out sagas going on
in Washington DC last night or early
this
morning I guess Naomi Biden Joe Biden's
granddaughter um there was a a
government vehicle outside her house
that was being broken into and some
Secret Service agents
were [__] throwing gunfire or some
[__] I'm not sure what the hell's going
on I was
just made aware of this before I came on
air
so very strange stuff maybe we'll get to
the bottom of that today but I
definitely want to get to these clipse
of s s
h s
Grandpa freaking out yelling the quiet
part out loud I want to send all all all
the people who hate me to the gas
chamber all right
Hitler all right sounds good that's
great I again I I know a lot of people
are a little upset and people are
getting a little terrified of this folks
I'm telling
you they're making it to where
everyone's going to see what's coming
coming and it's gonna make the choice
obviously
clear this [__] boneheaded idea that
we should be listening to polls tell us
that this country thinks that Joe Biden
is less popular in the aggregate than
Donald Trump you are some dumb sons of
[__]
stop it stop that's the dumbest [__]
I've ever heard in my
life you're not understanding how the
whole thing
works last
Tuesday this country in red states of
Ohio and Virginia folks they both have
Republican
Governors [__] Ohio elected JD Vance
over Tim
Ryan those same [__] that went
and voted for that [__] box JD Vance
went and voted to enshrine Women's
Health Care rights and Reproductive
Rights into their state
constitution I know it feels weird but
we are in shape for our democracy we
just have to keep leaning in we do not
have to be
scared we don't have to listen to
[__] polls neither this is
ridiculous we have two actual polls that
matter two of them two really good
[__] measurements of polls of the
attitude of the country 2022 when there
was it's going to be a red wave oh
government Republicans going to take
over everything they're gonna take over
everything you remember that [__] I told
you that whole [__] summer don't
listen that garbage it's trash it's lies
it's all [__] rigged poles that
Republicans are trying to convince the
country that Trump is popular when he's
not he's not popular and yes some people
especially young people think Joe
Biden's old yeah CUA he is old but that
doesn't make a [__] difference who
gives a rat's ass Trump's old too [__]
you oh he's old so is your guy what the
[__] the
difference there is a aund other things
that I could tell you the reason why
this country should vote
vote against Donald Trump than his
[__] age his age is so far down on
the [__] list of why we should not
vote for Donald Trump it's not even
funny so why the [__] are we standing
around talking about the other guy's age
get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense because the media wants you to
because they want to do a poll they want
to see how the country feels about Joe
Biden's age well son of a [__] isn't it
funny that people in their 20s think Joe
Biden's old no it's not that yes people
in their 20s and their 30s think Joe
Biden's old because to people in their
20s and the
30s Joe Biden's old so is Trump they're
[__] both old I don't know what to
tell you you remember this when you were
a kid right you're like
goddamn
goddamn my uncle's old as [__] and then
you got to be in your 30s and 40s and
you're like my uncle's only in his 60s I
thought he was old as my whole [__]
life it's dumb stupid [__] that we're
standing around listening to
polls when we have two ballot polls two
of them
2022 and 2023 that tell us the story
actually there's about four elections if
you want to know the honest truth
because there's some special elections
in there where red States like Kansas
Montana Kentucky said no you're not
going to touch our Reaper productive
rights you can [__] off they told
Republicans not just no but [__] no you
cannot mess with our
rights folks that matters that's a real
[__] poll and a Democrat won yes he's
an incumbent but a Democrat won in
Kentucky medical
marijuana and enshrining women's rights
to health care and their reproductive
privacy is enshrined in the Ohio
Constitution Republicans are really
pissed off about this oh they're going
to do everything they can to make sure
that the people the people are dumb the
people of Ohio don't know what the [__]
they're talking about we want to be
fascist apparently the Ohio Republicans
think that they're going to undo this
[__] yeah good luck okay take that to
the Supreme Court why don't you yeah all
right go go go to any state Missouri
tried this [__] too by the way to try to
overturn referendums I've talked about
this before my state of Missouri the
state of Missouri had a referendum on
the ballot to take the federal money
that the ACA gave them to finally take
the money the Obamacare money if you
want to get scary
Obamacare but the ACA money that the
federal government guarantees Missouri
voted to take that money they weren't
taking that money up until a couple
years ago that's right Missouri refused
to take ACA money because it was
Obamacare and it's literally the money
that [__] missourians paid into the
federal tax to get it back in healthcare
and the Republicans at the state refused
the money so that they didn't have money
to spend on health care that's right all
the shitty [__] Health Care results
in Missouri it's Republicans
fault not Democrats Democrats don't
[__] control Missouri they they
have't for
decades every every result that you see
in this country that is sh
shitty especially in red States is
probably because of uh I don't know
[__] Republicans run those
States and they make bad outcomes on
purpose to blame it on Democrats [__]
there they they did that all last year
and the year before here in Missouri oh
it's all Biden's fault oh education
sucks because it's Biden's fault well
the state runs education you [__]
idiots how how the don't Republicans
know that the States run education and
that count local local and County Boards
of Education
run their schools districts how don't
they [__] oh that's right because
they're [__] they're
delusional and it this project 2025
stuff is [__]
delusional it's
delusional honestly even when you look
at it on its face face and what they
want to do it's hard to even imagine how
it's even going to work or how they
would even Institute it in reality and
the reason why is because their idea is
to have Trump do
it do you remember when this
[__] was the president of the
United
States he couldn't even take a briefing
that didn't have his [__] name in it
because he couldn't pay attention long
enough because he's such a [__]
buffoon and and their their big
idea is to turn America into Nazi
Germany with this [__] idiot all
right go ahead let's let's let's see you
try that lean into that dumb
[__] someone else is pointing out here
in the chat that Mom Mom's for democra
moms moms for Liberty I'm sorry moms for
fascism the [__] with casseroles you
know those sons of [__] they all got
tra every [__] last one of
them I'm telling you I'm telling
you you have to be confident you have to
be optimistic we cannot get discouraged
and we cannot let discouragement breed
disengagement because it will and that's
what the media here's what the media is
trying to do they're like you know we
got they're they're in private rooms the
media who think they control you and
they control your brain in your thinking
I'm not [__] you this is how they
[__]
think this is this is where the media
always gets it [__] wrong they think
they control what we think which is
[__] wild stuff wild [__] stuff in
this day and age it's
2023 and they act like they's still only
three channels on
TV and there's one newspaper in your
town they're [__]
boneheads the media hasn't caught up to
what the [__] the what the [__] we're at
in present day not not let alone
thinking about the future they're so
[__] far behind again they still run
around acting like there's three Network
TV stations and one newspaper in your
goddamn Hometown they're dumb as dog
[__] that they can try to think that
they can convince
us people who have enough brain cells to
rub together they don't just believe
anything they [__]
hear but that's what they're doing
they're sitting in rooms are like you
know what we really got to scare these
people we cuz you know what you know
what really gets people motivated to
vote yeah we gotta scare him you know
fear porn we gotta get him Fe fear porn
Shut the [__] up point out the threat go
hey look see they want to be Nazis ah
look the Republicans are Nazis look they
put Mike Johnson a [__] Nazi is a
speaker of the house Donald Trump who
tried to overturn our government commit
a coup he's going to be the their next
nominee he's talking about shipping
people off the [__] gas Chambers oh
it's not complicated
stuff to [__] point it out it really
isn't that [__] it really isn't that
[__]
complicated and you can have an optimism
about it you can get people
strategically outraged not fear oh my
God there's nothing we can do there's
nothing we can do to stop it I'll stay
home and not vote because Trump's going
to win anyways look what the poll says
[__] out of here that's what happened
2016 get off your
ass and engageing your democracy that's
what you should be doing right now using
your strategic outrage [__] that [__]
[__] those polls and [__] what the media
says [__] them [__] them [__] them I'll
be right back right after these
messages we'll be right back Mark 60
seconds this is the Tony Michael
[Music]
podcast are you numb in alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy P's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product paron blanket I've got
you covered paron blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too Harden blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and there are 100% made in
the USA don't delay and get your pardon
blanket today for just
$999.99 actual pardon is not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the
show how was your [__]
weekend how was it what did you do did
you get
stoned I did did you get drunk I drank a
little bit I didn't get
[Music]
was are you ready for Thanksgiving
you're ready for the
holidays happy
holidays Merry Christmas Happy New Year
and go [__]
yourself no I'm serious did you have a
great uh Veterans Day did you have a
great weekend it was beautiful
outside again you should have if you
didn't get stone maybe you should have
if you didn't get have a few drinks
maybe you should have or maybe you
shouldn't have hell I don't know what
are you
doing I got baked I got baked a lot of
you
bought merch over the weekend I'm not
kidding you and I got a a thing this
morning that I've been working on now we
know we had the even my dog hates de
Cruise merch at the Tony
michaels.com but I have something to
unveil for you because the cat lovers
out there in the chat have been calling
for even my cat hates Ted Cruz and they
are now available even my cat hates Ted
Cruz the is your is your [__] allergic
to Ted Cruz oh my
God we were talking about that in the
producer's corner this morning how I'd
introduce it and that's how I was gonna
do it but oh man I figured I'd get in
trouble on YouTube if I would introduce
the my cat hates Ted Cruz merch by
saying is your [__] allergic to Ted
Cruz that should be a commercial
shouldn't it for the even my cat hates
Ted do you live in
Texas are you gonna vote
is your [__] allergic to Ted
Cruz I don't know maybe it could be a
good commercial if not you know maybe
your dog so even my dog hates Ted Cruz
and even my cat hates Ted Cruz merch is
now available here on the Tony
michaels.com you just go to the Tony
michaels.com pan on down just click the
my dog hates Ted Cruise merch it'll take
you to the store you can see the cat and
the dog merch I'll try to get some
coffee mugs and some other things coffee
mugs maybe some stickers in there in the
U in the merch store of the cat and the
dog but right now you can go get your
hoodie you can stay warm um you and your
your kitty cat can stay warm there and
get you all the discord's blowing up
with
the with memes oh
boy how's the chat doing today you guys
doing okay you guys want to shoot the
[__] for a while let's shoot the [__]
why not did you hear here maybe you guys
got some questions for me we haven't
done that in a while shoot the [__] I
guess I need some music for that hey rat
hey rat can you can you get us some
shoot the [__] uh music like a a jingle
you know what I mean I don't know
something good like um I don't know
shoot the [__] what do you what do you
guys
think talk to Tony write the question I
don't know what do you guys think get
get us a get us a jingle going okay
thank you thank you thank you all right
R to work on that while we're shooting
the [__] maybe we'll have that for you
by the end kayin says let's shoot the
[__] so if you got a question throw it
into throw it into the uh chat right now
put a question mark in the beginning of
it so I can see it because I got so many
so many chats here but did you hear
while I'm waiting on some questions here
because I know you guys will throw up
some questions H did you hear that Trump
died yes breaking news Trump has passed
away it's just the wrong one I I don't
I'm not feeling sorry I mean I don't
really feel sorry about this do you I
mean I don't Trump's sister Maryann
Trump Barry has died at age
86 [__] [__] man and people have been
telling me there's a
God people have been telling me there's
a God son of a
[__] well
not not a good enough one for that
matter he missed he [__]
missed I don't know you want me to feel
sorry for these
scumbags really this [__] this I mean
Donald Trump is a piece of [__] but
where do you think they [__] learned
this [__] you think he you think he just
became a piece of [__] and the rest of
his his family's great I mean there you
know there's Mary Trump she's like the
only one with the name Trump from that
family that's a worth a damn the only
one that's worth a damn it seems doesn't
it I mean even Tiffany who Donald Trump
doesn't even [__] know she's still
out there you know campaigning for this
[__] [__] box I mean if they had any
kind of [__] Humanity they'd be like
do not vote for my dad he is a piece of
[__] and so is his sister his sister is
a piece of [__] too she was a federal
judge you know that and she stepped down
when he became president but
apparently Trump is dead but it's just
the unfortunately it's not the correct
one I guess I don't know um kayin asked
Tony Michaels what Executives orders in
Biden's toolbox that be used to Jin up
some excitement are you saying just like
like what can what can the
administration do to to try to Hype up
voters is that what you're asking I
think that's what you're asking here
Kaylin is what can they do I mean
there's all sorts of tools in the toolbx
I guess um that was one of the things
that the
Administration has done is to try to
Hype uh a few things that he ran on but
there's a lot going on
and I mean I don't know that Joe Biden
needs to get up in the morning and think
about how to use the government to win
the election I mean he's doing a damn
good job on
backing American workers and that's and
that's helping and working like that's
you know that's a big huge um that's a
that's a big huge one when we talk about
that kind of stuff you know so I don't
know if there's any specific executive
orders that he can use to get to get
America excited other than just getting
up and putting his [__] shoes on and
doing his job so there's that um red
rocket rod says Where do you think he'll
bury her I I [__] I don't
[Music]
know depends on how many documents he
stuffs in her casket you know what I
mean he still got plenty of
documents and Chrissy says on Facebook
says I wonder if he'll bury Mar Lago oh
I doubt that no he ain't gonna bury her
next to Mar Lago Christine's on Facebook
says gonna bury her next to
Avana I don't know it could be everyone
wants to know where the [__] he's gonna
bury her
uh Mel makes a good point here Will
trump now use sister's death to try to
delay oh absolutely any kind of [__]
thing he can use to delay anything he'll
he'll do it he'll do it um Robbie says
will micro Johnson Outlast the CRS over
under on outlasting McCarthy so I
actually I I haven't watched the CR news
but my guesses is that they will not
pass ACR um and and if and if micro
Johnson passes the CR then what what
could
happen if if that is the case is that he
will have to do it with Democratic votes
and it will keep the government open and
my guess is is his speakership will be
As Dead As Trump's sister I'm just
saying I'm just saying I'm just I'm not
saying Trump killed his sister I'm not
saying that that's not what I'm saying
here but some people
[Music]
there it is let's shoot this [__] with
Tony yeah it's a good one that's thank
you rat thank you very much I like that
one let's shoot the [__] with Tony so
what other questions do we got here we
got we got a few more minutes to shoot
this [__] um here we go coko says can
small rant whip up some hip hop in the
AI I oh yeah we we can do hip hop we can
do just about
anything we can oh that was that wasn't
rap that was Derek's invention thank you
Derek for the sound there um sending it
to rat and getting it on the uptick but
yeah we can do hip hop there's all kinds
of stuff we can do there ain't anything
we can't do honestly with this AI stuff
um it's good Ronald says who isn't suing
Trump I mean that's a good question it's
probably
um to name the people who aren't suing
Trump um foggy says is that Mary Trump's
Mom Mary
Trump I mean
no
um I think if I remember right it's his
brother but did you know that that
Donald Trump and his sister
stole their brother's [__]
inheritance I don't know if you know
that or not now let's see what else do
we got here what other questions do we
have keep going with the
questions um Loki says Tony do you think
the asini will rewrite the Second
Amendment he wouldn't want Arn verman
that's exactly right Loki that's exactly
right it's kind of funny how that works
in fascist um
takeovers see if you go back and you
look at the history books you'll
learn that Adolf Hitler tried to
overturn the government once and he
tried to do it with the brown shirts
right and as soon as he actually came to
power all those violent brown shirts
that help him overthrow the government
he killed them
first because he knew they weren't loyal
subjects because they weren't loyal to
Germany and they were violent
they were militant so he didn't want the
people who were unloyal violent and
militant to turn on
him Billy boy says did Putin poison her
hell I don't know you think Putin
poisoned Trump's sister I doubt
that I doubt that there's plenty of
compromise that could have been on that
uh crystal says how many scaramucci will
Johnson last I actually think he last a
lot more scare of muchi than you think
he
will because I think even if Mike
Johnson is indicating that he's going to
keep the government open I think he's a
he's a he's not gonna do
that I mean I could be wrong but I'm
guessing they close the
government what do you think the whole
[__] deal was getting rid of McCarthy
and getting a new
speaker so let's see what other
questions do we have here we're shooting
the [__] today so if you got a question
put it in the chat
what else do we get Allen on on Facebook
says is there anything along the human
rights issue he can
use are you talking about Biden it's it
feels like you're talking about
Biden um with the human rights thing the
question that Caitlin asked earlier like
like as far as executive orders I mean I
I guess there is but the thing with the
executive orders
and this is the you
know the terrible Loop that we get
into right it's a terrible Loop we get
into because we believe that the
president of the United States has the
power with the executive um you know
authority to do certain things and he he
or she does they do have the ability to
some degree but what you have to
understand is as soon as another
president comes into Power th those
executive orders can be wiped
with another executive order I mean
that's Biden spent I don't know if you
remember this but he had stacks of
executive orders just undoing the
garbage that Trump had done and just
trying to unfuck our government and
unfuck the
regulations that Trump had set into
place and and unfuck some of the
directions that some of the agencies
were going because you know he's an
idiot Trump's an idiot so Biden spent a
lot of time trying to unfuck stuff with
the with that were executive orders and
he was trying to unfuck them with
another executive order so it's a stupid
[__] Loop we
do now I I think that's what makes Joe
Biden one of the most effective
presidents that we've had in a long time
is because he's very measured in how he
operates his executive branch a lot of
people get pissed off about it I know um
this morning they were talking about
Betto oror disagreeing with Joe Biden
about the
border and you know BET's and entitles
to his opinion um he doesn't have to say
it out loud but he's entitled to it and
he can say it out loud if he wants to if
he wants to look like an idiot he can do
that um but you know the one thing that
I think people fail to recognize
sometimes is that no matter who the
president is no matter how great of a
president they are how shitty of a
president they are it does not matter uh
when when you get in the realm of that
there's just [__] outside people's
control and there's just there's just
literal I mean you take natural
disasters for a prime example a lot of
Republicans refuse to send federal aid
to Blue States but they want it for
their red States right but the people in
the red States and the people in the
blue States no matter if it's a tornado
in [__] Alabama or if it's a
goddamn hurricane in Florida those
[__] people can't can't prevent that
[__] from happening right I mean they
can't just nuke a [__] hurricane and
it h stop happening right you can't nuke
a tornado and it just stop these are
[__] Beyond some people's control it's
beyond the leaders
control no matter who the leader is
doesn't
matter and when you start to use
executive orders to try to manage stuff
outside of your
control um you're getting into territory
that the executive has too much power
the the problem that we really have when
we consider executive orders in our
style of government the the our Republic
the Constitution that we have and how
it's laid out is
that we should actually give more power
back to the House of Representatives I
know that sounds scary in this moment
that with Mike Johnson being the speaker
and the Republicans having control of
the house but if we actually gave more
power back to the house we the people
could actually get more accomplished
of what we wanted to accomplish one
reason why is because they truly
represent a
constituency right think about it for a
second um when they're when they're
measuring out districts and [__] so
[__]
gerrymandered that really honestly you
know the racist white people are
represented by a racist white
[__] right they're so goddamn
Jerry mannered in some of these
districts but that's really where our
representation comes from and the best
part of about it is we get to they have
a two-year term limit and I know a lot
of people are like oh we need to put
term limits on Congress we do have term
limits their term is limited to two
[__] years and we can fire
them how do I I never understood how
Americans don't get
that it's it's always been a lie that's
been told to the American people that we
need term
limits yeah that we got term limits Oh
you mean how many terms well that's
really [__] dumb what if you what if
what if constituents have a really good
[__] politician that listens to them
is a serious [__] politician and goes
and does the work that their District
wants them to do why in the [__] should
that District not be able to keep
electing that that politician if they're
doing a really good job being their
[__] representative that's dumb as
dog [__] and
frankly when you when you look at some
of the models that some of these state
governments have like my my uh my home
state of Missouri put term limits on in
the 1990s and these [__] idiots don't
know how to pass legislation they have
no clue they've never looked at a piece
of legislation in their [__] life and
what happens is all the big Lobby gets
in the way and starts to pump in what
they want to have happen and they're
teaching these [__] idiots how to
legislate instead of just knowing how to
legislate and be serious about it so I
guess roundabout way Allen is there
anything along human rights issues that
he could that he could write as
executive order I think that's what
you're asking is that yeah he could do
that but really the human rights issue
needs to be in our Congress we need to
pass legislation we need to ratify the
the
erra we need to codify women's
Reproductive Rights we need we need to
more well defined what [__] hate
speech is and what hate crimes are
that's what we need to do those are the
tin and piece of leg istion that need to
be debated by our Representatives that
we elect in the house and in the Senate
but the Senate a senate isn't a
representative of of your District it's
not that's why it's a six-year term hell
it used to be that the most the time the
governors would appoint a senator until
we went to where they are elected
officials but I mean Most states you got
blue cities red rural areas and the
Senate is sometimes represents the state
appropriately and sometimes they
don't based on the population and how
it's laid out so um I hope that answers
the question I
[Music]
know yeah there we
go there's some hip-hop for you someone
is asking if we had hip-hop or the
ability to do hip-hop there you go let's
shoot this [__] with Tony all right well
we're getting down to the bottom of the
shoot this [__] I really want to show
you the E clipse of this [__] this
[__]
um um I I really want to put you know
this clip on on blast because you got to
see this and paired with the clip where
he's like oh blood poisoning he's really
saying a lot of Nazi stuff a lot of 1930
style solutions that he wants for this
country um it's gross and vile and then
you couple it with what they want with
project 2025 you really start to see it
you really start to see it uh let's see
what what other question do we have any
more here in the end what would you call
cinema cinema
enema that's what I would call her enema
oh well Cinema see Kirsten Cinema in
Arizona actually duped the people who
helped get her elected that's why she
can't run as a Democrat you see that's
why she can't do that the reason why is
because if she would run as a Democrat
she would lose the primary because she
pissed off all the
primary uh campaign workers in Arizona
like they worked really hard to get her
ass
elected and then it's not really about
the promises made and the promises
broken it's that she turned her back on
the people who in Arizona who got her
elected the people who worked on the
ground who knocked [__] doors for her
who [__] did who did foam Banks she
basically told them to get [__] I
don't care about you people anymore I
care more about special interest money
than you and I care more about you know
aligning myself with Mitch McConnell and
Republicans so I can cause trouble in
the Senate because they're paying me to
do that so so kirston Cinema can get
[__] and that's and that's a good
prime example of how [__] term limits
work you piss off the voters you're out
[__] you're [__] you're gone goodbye
see you it's been nice knowing you have
a good [__]
trip that's that's the point and that's
and that's why we shouldn't give so much
power to the
executive we shouldn't give so much
power to the executive we shouldn't no
matter who the [__] it is whether it's
Trump or it's [__] Biden or Obama or
whoever the [__] it is we should not be
giving them that much power we should we
should to keep the power in our
hands and when we get to elect the
United States Senators but more more
than anything when we elect our Congress
people that is where the power is that
is where the power is so don't go
anywhere I we'll be right back I promise
right back right after this thanks for
shooting the
[__] we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott finder
for just
$29.99 plus you'll also receive our next
rep as a bonus just Loop it around your
neck to travel with ease but call right
now and we'll double the offer that's
two boycott binders and two neck straps
for just
$29.99 boycott binders brought to you by
the same makers of bind just full of
women jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast oh welcome back to the show got
some more comments here that I want to
bring before we get to the the
asini
[Music]
asol the asini
clip he's talking about shipping
shipping all of us to the gas g
just like the shart Army once man oh man
the shart Army is desperate for Donald
Trump to do their fascist bidding oh my
God they really aren't Mony librarian
brings up a really good point it's
supposed to be coal branches exactly
it's supposed to be the executive is not
supposed to have more power than a
legislative branch or the judicial
branch and the like there's supposed to
be checks and balances in there which
there are um but executive orders I feel
like to me it kind of sometimes
oversteps it depends on the aim of the
executive order right I really think
that's that's the key um to rather it's
co-equal when an executive writes an
executive order is what what defines
co-equal uh when they do that so what
what is the aim of the executive order
so that's that's important Underdog
asked a question here Biden only won the
uh the swing states by around
320,000 votes Tony do you think the
Democratic party should concentrate on
the they are going to concentrate on
those Six States and I've said this
before this is the um um this is the
nice part about a
rematch the one advantage of it is you
know where the Biden votes are and you
know where the Trump votes are right
like essentially now the demographics
have shifted a bit um and they've
shifted in a couple different ways
number one the demograph demographics
have shifted on age a bit in some of
those swing States but the other thing
too is they've shifted on attitude
because you got to remember from the
2020 election till now Republicans have
been like oh yeah you want Reproductive
Rights [__] you you don't get
Reproductive Rights this is gonna be
handmaid's tail [__] like they've
leaned into that attitude right so like
that's happened since then so there's
that effect
too and we see that and we see see that
in the special elections and we see that
in the the uh the 2022 election uh and
we see that in the 2023 election as well
so we see that in these special
elections these referendums that are
happening in these states especially a
state like
Ohio I mean Ohio is not a blue state
folks Ohio is not a blue State Trump won
that [__] twice JD Vance beat Tim Ryan
Tim Ryan is no goddamn bleeding heart
liberal he's no [__] Lefty he's not a
Tim Ryan is far from some sort of Bernie
bro communist you know what I mean just
so far from it and JD Vance still beat
him in Ohio and we watched in Ohio
the the enshrinement of women's
Reproductive Rights win win
overwhelmingly and it it I I gotta say
that that poll [__] that's the poll
that matters right and and again underd
dog yes Democrats are going to go and
tear that tear that poll the ballot the
ballot numbers apart in Ohio because not
only are they going to have to win uh
that presidential race there they're
gonna have to win the senate race for
shared Brown which uh in in a
presidential election it's damn good
that we have an incumbent going into
that presid IAL election in Ohio so that
way we can still split the party in Ohio
in our United States Senate so that's
important because now we we're probably
going to be down a seat already because
Joe Mansion is walking away from his
seat which a republican will win that
seat in West Virginia Garand Dam de Tony
Michaels says November 13
12:58
PM that there will be a republican who
wins Joe mansion's seat uh speaking of
Ohio and politicians there Mel here on
YouTube says how do we get rid of Jim I
don't report sex crimes
Jordan you vote and you Jerry Mander the
[__] out of the state when you get
control over it it's what you
do you Jerry Mander the [__] out of it
Democrats I've said this for a long time
the de what democrats should do in all
the blue States and anytime they get any
kind of control and power they should
Jerry Mander the [__] out of the state
so much so that Mark Elias has to the
Democrats that's when Republicans will
really take be taken back they'll be
like whoa [__] maybe we should stop
Jerry mandering because as soon as we
weaponize what they're weaponizing
against us they will
stop they will I shouldn't say they'll
stop it'll take a while for them to re
they're [__] boneheads they're
[__] boneheads I mean look at this
guy this Shard arming A Shard army guys
here says Cinema is a patriot I respect
her yeah we know we know you piece a
[__] why you respect
her because she's sold out to a bunch of
special interest yeah we get it she sold
out to a Harland Hitler yeah we get it
CH we know we know you want your
politicians listening to the rich and
doing the bidding of billionaires and
and gazillionaires in this country yeah
we get it we know we know you want your
B you're you're delusional as [__]
man where does where does [__]
politicians going to the hill
and giving [__] fellatio to
billionaires help you dummy you're such
a [__] idiot what a [__] dumb [__]
Jesus Christ how do you you know I I'm
so surprised you still show up here
every day but you know it's crazy all
right let's get to some of these clips I
want to get here's a clip U from MSNBC
this is uh Jose Diaz Bard I think this
is talking about how Trump died yeah I
know it's not the one you want but it's
about how Trump died it's it's the best
we're going to get todaying news
concerning former president Trump's
family NBC News has learned that Donald
Trump's oldest sister Maryanne Trump
Barry has died no NBC News correspondent
Von Hillard is with us Von what more do
we
know at the age of 86 marann Trump Barry
has passed away she was notably the
former federal judge Jose who stepped
down from her position in 2019 she was
serving on the appet court out of New
Jersey at the time that she stepped down
in 2019 you know I got to say he's an
ugly son of a [__] right and the apples
don't fall far from the tree do they I'm
just pointing it out what do you want
from
me already well in her 80s at that point
she is one of four Trump siblings there
is only one uh sibling of Donald Trump's
that now remains his brother Robert Pass
well that's sad as [__] isn't it boohoo
all right well let's move on
what you want from me [__] I can't get
sad about that [__] I the only reason
why I get sad about it is because people
say there's a God toon there's a what
there's a
God don't you think he would have got
that one right come on he wouldn't have
[__] [__] that one up Wy have um
let's move
on you're gonna be mad at me let's move
on to um Biden's Biden's granddaughter
here is a here's a little report this
morning was on CNN talking about the the
shooting there was a shooting outside
her house apparently in DC I guess there
was a some sort of federal vehicle
unmarked vehicle or some [__] outside
her um her building and the secet
service started firing on it let's
listen this is CA news Central and we do
begin with breaking news this hour at
least three suspects are at large after
Secret Service agents opened fire on
suspects that they s say were breaking
into an unmarked government vehicle this
happened l late last night let's get
straight over to the White House
Priscilla Alvarez is standing by for us
with more and Priscilla you're picking
up some more details about what is
actually happening here tell
us that's right this is a detail for
Naomi Biden it was an agent that was
involved uh in this incident now
according to uh that according to a
source familiar now in this statement
from the Secret Service they said the
following on November 12th around 11:58
p.m. in the Georgetown neighborhood of
Washington DC Secret Service agents
encountered possibly three individuals
breaking a window on a parked and
unoccupied government vehicle this
statement goes on to say during this
encounter a federal agent discharged a
service weapon and it is believed no one
was struck again according to a force
familiar this was an agent involved with
at Naomi Biden the uh president's
granddaughter's detail now they in
addition note that the uh suspects fled
in a red vehicle and there is a regional
uh Lookout that has been issued that is
all the details that we have
right now but it appears again that this
happened in the late hours of Sunday and
we're learning uh details by the minute
oh okay so
nothing okay it's weird someone is
bringing into a car and secret service
starts shooting at them and it happens
to be this is CA news Central and we do
begin with breaking news this hour three
suspects are at large after Secret
Service agents opened fire on suspects
pause God damn
it it's [__] ridiculous isn't it come
on this is ridiculous I mean obviously
obviously Shez and The Shard Army want
to impeach Joe Biden because Naomi
Biden's um secret service detail shot
and fired at some I'm not kidding you he
he wants him to impeach for anything
look look look look you can impeach
Biden for so many reason this is what
you're talking about in the Facebook
Chat man what the [__] are you what the
[__] are you doing
[Music]
yeah we know sh you piece of [__]
bit apparently rat's been working in the
background for your Shir Armory there
shz he says first he was installed Not
Elected well I mean you can call it
however you want chz but the the
Congress voted to certify the election
so I mean whatever you want to call it
we elected him they certified the
election Congress certified the
certification of the election and then
he was sworn in by the chief justice so
I don't know if you know how this [__]
works but that's not called install
that's called elected and then he says
second he can't think clearly anyways
third he seile makes
mistakes these are impeachable offenses
you're a dumb son of a [__] oh my God
you you go on to say interesting why
doesn't the House GOP have the bank
records because there are no bank
records you stupid bastard can't can't
we impeach Biden on the Afghanistan mess
no because it was Trump's plan you
[__]
dummy you're such an idiot it ain't no
wonder you're so damn stupid in the
Facebook comments it ain't no wonder you
don't look like you know what the [__]
you're talking about because you don't
go [__] go look I don't want you to
stop watching the show Shez but when we
get off the air go [__] look some of
this stuff up quit coming here and
asking stupid questions go look some of
these stupid questions up maybe just
maybe you'll find that you could pluck
your head out of your ass long enough to
understand that they can't impeach Biden
that's why they haven't yet you [__]
idiot the answer the answer to your
question the answer to your question is
right in front of your face man and to
all The Shard Army out there most of the
answers to your questions are right in
front of your face speaking of Shard
Army I got to show you a couple of these
clips I really wanted to get to them um
but you know you gotta you gotta do what
you can do when you can do
it and we're GNA do it right now so
here's a couple of Clips here's Adam
mockler Adam's doing great work out
there I don't know if you guys seen this
guy's account but Adam's doing some
great work out there actually
undermining the the ability for trumpers
to think uh shz Hey pay attention buddy
pay attention this is you the guy
sitting here that he's questioning this
is you and with your dumb stupid
thoughts listen I was a Trumper but I
think it's time to change I I'm just
kind of tired of his attitude I think
he's in it for himself what do you think
about Donald Trump being charged with
conspiracy to Def fraud the United
States I personally think it's a Witch
Hunt you think so yeah I think they're
just they'll do anything to get rid of
him because they don't like him do you
know what they're saying he did
basically what they're accusing him of
is gathering fake electors to try to
certify the results in his favor in
multiple States He also called Georgia
asking him to flip the results of the
election do you think there's any truth
in that I think he probably did so if he
did it then don't you think he should be
prosecuted if they have if they have
proof yes so it's not quite a Witch Hunt
they're just trying to gather the proof
and stuff basically right interesting
are you a fan of Mike Pence no okay sh
you're not paying attention yes sir it
is a Witch Hunt preach brother you're
not you're not understanding you're not
understanding the guy just he admitted
he said it was a Witch Hunt and then he
admitted that it that it wasn't Chez you
[__] dummy are you watching the same
video I'm watching this is real this is
not AI this is [__]
real again if you just open your [__]
ears for a half a second open your
[__] eyeballs for a half a second and
realize that you [__] bowing down to
fascist is not going to serve you well
nor is it going to serve anyone else
well besides the [__] fascist in
power but listen listen my friend listen
why not and I think he's unloyal you
think he's unloyal to Donald Trump yeah
in what way I think I think he's just
now that he's way he's badmouth and you
know why didn't he do something while he
was in there well what Donald Trump
wanted him to do was overturn the
results of a democratic election would
you prioritize the Constitution over
Trump yes I would the Constitution comes
first so when Trump asked Pence to
override the results of the election he
was wrong Trump was wrong I believe so
yes and interesting so you can
understand why is bad mouthing him now
he's trying to set the precedent that
Trump isn't someone who should be in
office that's right yeah yeah yeah right
yeah did you catch that Chez I'm sure
you were commenting yeah yeah Mike Pence
is an [__] yeah preach brother Mike P
I mean I'm an in Gren Mike Pence is a
piece of [__] trash Mike Pence is a
piece of
[__] there's no way you won't get me to
agree on that point
but the fact that you people think that
Mike Pence is badmouthing Trump now
because because Pence is bad no he's
doing it because he he [__] tried to
hang the guy you understand that right
tried to hang the guy oh and then you
say this stupid
[__] oh man I you know I thought Shaz
was real until this comment I thought he
was real I thought him and The Shard
Army
were
Army Shaz in The Shard
Army he says I like Dean Phillips he's a
good Democrat what do you mean by that
what makes him a good Democrat shz what
makes him a good Democrat again I could
do the same stupid [__] that Adam uh
mockler does in these in these clips but
you wouldn't [__] walk away from
it you still wouldn't have enough brain
cells to rub together so there's there's
Adam let me give you another taste of
some of this interviews that Adam's been
doing it's actually really good because
he just doesn't uh mock them he actually
tries to do a little bit of
deprogramming you know what I mean here
here's another great one Shaz maybe you
should take a lesson on this one and The
Shard Army could get a lot of out of
this one look at this watch this guy
just get totally stumped on this well
Democrats started the
KKK you you know that oh Democrats
started the KKK they're the racist okay
all right go on Democrats were the ones
that were for slavery the Democrats were
the ones that come up the Jim Crow stuff
even if all of that were true about
slavery which party flies the
Confederate flag today a lot of a lot of
the Democrats you really think Democrats
fly the Confederate flag Democrats that
yes overwhelmingly you'll see a I could
do a poll of the audience here I would
imagine that most of my audience votes
for serious people uh to to represent
them and what I mean by that is that
they vote for a a party of serious
people not for Democrats but just you
know serious people in general and I
would imagine that the people who vote
for serious people don't fly the
Confederate flag because it's not a
serious thing to fly the Confederate
flag in 2023 it just isn't it's not a
serious thing it makes you look stupid I
mean you have the right to do it I
actually believe that people have the
right to fly the Confederate flag on
their private property absolutely you
look like a dumb [__] but you have the
right to look [__] stupid in this
country frankly I want you to exercise
your right for me to know that you're a
dumb [__] please let us all know that
you're stupid as [__] when you fly the
Confederate
flag but this is really dumb stuff this
guy doesn't really believe this does he
or is he just making this [__] up
Federate flag right next to a trump flag
that's just how it works now I I haven't
seen that overwhelmingly you really
Democrats were did you hear what this
guy just said no I haven't seen that no
I haven't I haven't seen I haven't seen
people hang the Trump flag that's all
[__] come on you really was it
Democrats or Republicans trying to take
down Confederate
statues Confederate statues which party
was trying to take down Confederate
statues
feels like Jeopardy doesn't it but Adam
does a great job of answering these
questions because this bonee head at
this moment you can see his face here
realizes what the [__] he walked
into he realized that he [__] walked
into the truth oh [__] this guy's not
gonna let me get away with just spouting
out a bunch of [__] into a
microphone so all of a sudden look at
thisy guy's face he's like oh [__] oh
you got
me you youngster you got me on
listen what's so yeah what's the stat
you got to do with you're saying that
Democrats are pro Confederate but
weren't Democrats trying to remove
Confederate
[Music]
statues more of The Shard
Army hey Shaz this is your Shard Army
this is this is who is fighting on your
side and folks if you if you despise The
Shard Army this is who our opposition is
these people who can't put Collective
thoughts together now the problem is
they [__]
vote they [__] because they have the
right to vote so they [__] vote so
what the [__] are you gonna
do are you gonna not engage in your
democracy or you going to go out there
and challenge these [__] idiots when
someone's like well it was the Democrat
that were for the
KKK it was for the it was the Democrats
that were for
slavery yeah you clearly don't
understand ideology you clearly do not
understand that parties change
ideology there were wars fought people
died to change these ideologies and
these ideology shifted and people got
killed because the ideologies got
shifted you [__]
boneheads how don't you know this
parties aren't ideology ideology are not
parties that's not a
thing until we get over this mess of
Americans not understanding how [__]
politics
works then we're not going to get
anywhere because this bonehead believes
that oh yeah it it was the Democrats
that were Confederates and and support
slavery but he can't put enough [__]
thought into it that that when he was
offended the Democrats wanted to take
down Confederate monuments that he was
the one that was Pro
Confederacy so now he's the one who
supports slavery is he a Democrat does
that make him a Democrat you stupid [__]
why are they doing that because they're
anti-confederate
no they're not why are they trying to
remove the stat ises them because
they're trying to change the history of
our country take a camera and go
interview all these black people that
are here okay and you ask them three
black people that are here you ask
them just short
circuits again just totally [__]
short circuits
then it's untenable and and here's The
Shard Army's leader one of their leaders
that comes here every day here's his
response to it impeach George Bush and
Hillary
dude you're [__] outside your [__]
you're you are outside the guard rails
of
reality you're not even thinking
straight like and if you are a bot they
need to rewrite your [__] your
[__] code
man because I just showed you a video of
you short
circuiting I just show yeah it's chat
GPT 3.5 not 4.0 get the [__] upgrade
Chez get the [__] upgrade get the
[__] pay for the [__] upgrade so you
can come
here and
chat decently you don't even [__]
make any sense [__] and when you type
something in like this dude like I mean
here let me let me show you let me show
you Brandon says Shaz is in is a cultist
he certainly
is um rocket rods says they don't make
any [__]
sense it's it's bone ended
stuff it's it's crazy
stuff I mean I can't even believe that
you you absolutely I demand respect [__]
out of here you don't get you're not
going to get an ounce of respect for me
my friend and here's the thing if you
think my respect is going to go beyond
you staying in the chat and me bringing
up comments and slamming you and [__]
with you so the audience can see how to
handle this [__] because that's one
thing this country has done way too
[__] long way too [__] long just
be easy on dumb [__] like you that's
one thing we need to get over in this
country that we can't offend people [__]
that offend Chaz like a
[__] like I do every day you
hurting my feelings I don't give a [__]
if I hurt shaz's feelings I don't give a
[__] if I hurt The Shard Army's feelings
did you listen to the [__] song when
you came in Shaz
about
snowflakes huh you're the [__]
snowflake man and I'm melting your ass
you dumb bastard how do you why do you
think fascist look to one autocratic
leader because they're weak you're
[__] weak that you worship Donald
Trump and Ronda santis you're [__]
weak I don't worship Joe Biden I ain't
got a [__] Joe Biden vag I don't sit
here and pimp and comment go to [__]
people dude people have been pointing
out that you're going to not just my
show but show after show after show
after show after show after show after
show and commented in their chat now I
don't know who the [__] pays you to do
all this but you obviously don't have a
job or you live in your mom's basement
not really sure which it
is but I you you I you I don't give a
[__] what you
demand it's not gonna happen my
friend Beth says why do you spend so
much time on CH
it's not Shaz because it's been fake
Gabe before and then it was Dustin Shaz
will say something dumb and I'll have to
[__] boot him and then it'll be
another [__] soldier from The Shard
Army okay it's not just shz the point is
is that you should treat these people in
a certain way and they need they need to
be stuffed in a garbage can when when
they pop their [__] stupid little
heads out that's the problem that we had
with Trump is that we didn't smash that
[__] we didn't smash that [__] and get
rid of that [__]
slug that's why we're in the situation
we're in because this country wasn't
willing to look at people and say that's
dumb as [__] [__] what you're saying
that's the stupidest [__] I have ever
heard out of someone's [__] mouth and
you have no clue what you're talking
about and until you figure out what the
[__] you're talking about please please
do not vote and come back and and tell
me when you figure this [__]
out
just the way it's going to be because
it's not just it's not
just it's not just Shaz right he's just
the [__] easy Target in the [__]
Facebook
comments he's been hired by the DeSantis
campaign to come here and type in Dan
santis 2024 because Dan santis is so
[__] worthless he can't even walk on
a pair of high heels
decent
so
anyways let's get let's get to some more
Clips shall we shall we thanks for the
comment Beth I'm glad you're here every
day and I'm glad you're commenting and
I'm glad you're worried about you know
what the show is and why we're doing it
but really honestly I just want to show
people how to how to handle people like
Chez because it's ridiculous we
shouldn't have to handle this [__]
[Music]
[__]
Shaz and The Shard Army I demand
respect well you can go demand it
somewhere else then
[__] oh hey here's your little election
Den Shaz here's The Shard Army's
election listen to this [__] I'm proud
and strong election I'm a very proud
election
denier oh okay he's a very proud
election he's a he's a he's a pro-
forced birther he loves forced birth oh
he bues forth birst and you know what
he's going to do is he's going to he's
going to [__] punish
women if they have abortions he said it
out loud I didn't say that [__]
grandpa said that and he's an election
denier oh okay well you know that's cool
as if we didn't know that [__] speaking
of uh denying Donald Trump this is
[__] great I'm gonna put this on a
loop I'm gonna mute it though because I
don't I don't know if you saw this that
Donald Trump showed up at the UFC match
um this weekend and everyone thought
that it made him presidential or some
[__] I'm not sure what how they think
this [__] but a at this same match Bill
Burr the comedian and his wife are
sitting right behind him you can see
Trump here and this is kind of a
transition from one shot to another but
you can see Bill bur here watch what his
wife does behind
him she gives him the double [__]
finger this is how you treat this
[__] in public right there see
that bill bur's wife gives him the
special treatment right here
now again Donald Trump showing up to UFC
fight doesn't make doesn't
make Trump any kind of special person I
mean Bill Burr is there his wife is
there and she's flipping him off so how
does UFC how does this make it to where
it's some kind of fasy thing I I don't
understand
this like I get that the stoies out
there you know there's a lot of stoies
out there and they and they [__] they
get all you know crazy about Travis
Kelce and Taylor Swift [__] you know
they get all crazy about this kind of
[__] so they get crazy about this kind
of stuff and they thought it was so
offensive I can't believe she flipped
him off why why can't you believe that
there's all kinds of people in this
[__] country that would love to flip
that son of a [__] off I hope my I hope
I never get within spitting distance of
him oh [__] I'm just saying I'm not
saying I would I'm just saying that kind
and I can spit pretty [__] far like I
can Hawk a lugie and man I can launch
that some [__] have you ever seen
someone launch a lugie I [__] I can get
it going at least at least if I get if I
get a lot of ass into it you know like
when you lean back and you really get
some ass into it I could probably get
that [__] to go 1520
feet so I I and I'm not saying I would
that's not what I'm saying I'm just
saying I wouldn't want to be within that
distance of him you know anything
outside that distance I i' certainly
would give him the middle finger but and
here it is at the UFC match Donald Trump
getting the popularity contest he gets a
two rating two out of two middle fingers
from Bill Burr's
wife oh son of a [__] that's so funny
you know what's even better is you can't
really you can't really tell it here but
at the very end this is Kid Rock right
here at the very end and he's drinking
Bud Light
you see that in that [__] cup that's
Bud Light and he's pointing he's like
look I got my queer beer look everybody
I got my queer bear these [__] idiots
thought I hated Bud Light and I love Bud
Light what a [__] bunch of
idiots good Lord no that's how you got
it that's how you got it okay let's see
uh here is another clip of Donald Trump
let me see if I can find it here did
here it is okay and Chris Webb has this
this is from uh msnbc's covers this
morning but this is this is the clip
from his little Nazi rally in New
Hampshire and I'm serious it's a Nazi
rally listen in honor of our great
veterans on Veterans Day we pledge to
you that we will root out the Communists
marxists fascist and the radical left
thugs that live like Vermin within the
conf of our country that lie and steal
and cheat on elections the threat from
outside forces is far less Sinister
dangerous and Grave than the threat from
within man he really projects hard
doesn't he at the
end he well let me let me give it to you
again you know he calls he calls people
Vermin um and we all know that that's a
salute to musolini and Hitler but here
here listen to the end how he project
the threat from outside forces is far
less Sinister dangerous and Grave than
the threat from
within yep sure is but let's listen to
the first part again let's go through
that because the Vermin part is the part
that I want everyone to take away from
this because that really truly is the
reason why I'm showing you this now the
projection at the end you can always
guess that Donald Trump's going to
project I mean that's always the case
with
assho
as um but I want you to get this first
part where he talks about verman
communist and
Marxist listen to this really listen to
it again in honor of our great veterans
on Veterans Day we pledge to you that we
will root out the Communists marxists
fascists and the radical left thugs that
live like Vermin within the confines of
our country within the confines of our
country you see I again I know that it
feels like Donald Trump came up with
this [__] right but it really is Steph
Miller Jason Miller all these [__]
Nazis that are sitting there reading
Haron Hitler's sign copy of minec and
really studying musolini speeches and
trying to figure out how to make sure to
to how to continue this rhetoric of
Exterminating
Americans because that's truly what he's
saying right now there's some vile
people in this country I'm not I'm not
goingon to I'm not going to beat around
the bush there's some vile [__]
people in this
country you know who they are they say
vile [__] crazy [__] about other
Americans want wanting to to legislate
people out of
existence wanting to make sure that
people can't be who they want to be
marry who they want to marry love who
they want to love get the [__] out of
here with this nonsense make sure women
can't drive to a doctor's appointment
you [__] kidding
me come on
man but This Vermin talk listen to it
again listen to it one more time in
honor of our great veterans or honor of
our great veterans what the hell does
that mean Veterans Day we pledge to you
that we will root out the Communists
marxists fascist and the radical left
thugs that live like Vermin within the
confines of our country and live like
Vermin in the confines of our country
now I don't know if the shart Army knows
this I don't know if you've done your
research yet shart
Army but in 1930s in Italy and Germany
fascists came to power now they weren't
like these kind of fascists these nink
kaboot Nazis right this guy and these
people here are [__] n Boop Nazis
even the guy back here who probably is
wearing stolen bow I mean it is a trump
[__] rally what what do you want from
me half the people there with probably
Amo veteran [__] on are [__] stolen
Bor what what do you want from me hey
[__] you he's a [__] fraud they're
[__] frauds don't get on to
me but here's the
thing in 1930s Germany and
Italy not only were they using the word
vermin and it first started with
musolini but in Germany they were they
were depicting
cartoons as of Jewish people as
rats rats and they would they would talk
about it as an
infestation they are de he's
dehumanizing people just like the shart
Army does when they talk about I don't
know the lgbtq community commun when
they act like they're not going to let
women go to doctor's appointments making
them second class citizens not having
privacy in their doctor what man do you
know would be okay with the [__]
government getting involved in the
privacy of their doctor's office huh
what [__] man especially any white
man with old wrinkly balls and power
anywhere they
wouldn't but they would use political
cartoons in the 1930s because they
didn't have the Ender webs back then
they would depict in in cartoons and
pictures and drawings that all Jews and
Jewish people in Germany it was an
infestation and they would use a rat or
Vermin as the
phrase listen to what the [__] he says
again I know it's one more time to you
that we would will root out the
Communists marxists fascists and the
radical left thugs that live like Vermin
within the confines of our country they
don't belong here they're not humans
they're Vermin they're thugs they're
marxists they're communist and we will
root them
out listen folks there is an Insurgency
in this country a violence an Insurgency
of delusion an Insurgency of fascist but
I am highly confident
us as a democracy even with the problems
that our justice department and our
justice system has that we can prop
prosecute people who are in the
Insurgency and committing domestic
terrorist acts in this country including
this [__] [__] that's right I believe
the Department of Justice and the court
system is highly capable of Prosecuting
this [__] [__] right
here take some time there is a process I
know
I know a lot of people are impatient
about it but I'm highly confident in it
and and little [__] like this saying
[__] [__] like he just said about how
he's gonna root out
Vermin in a time where
anti-Semitism is on the [__]
rise he he doesn't understand what he's
saying but he knows what he's
doing
he knows what he's
doing big step fan uh likes that I use
the word [__] to describe Trump big step
fan on Twitch he is a [__] he's a
[__] He's one he's probably King [__]
isn't he I would imagine this [__]
[__] ass
[__] [__] ass [__] he is
okay well let's see what else we have um
from from some [__] ass [__]
here's a great clip oh
man woo baby remember they
blamed Republicans lost last week in
Ohio and
Virginia on the the point of women's
healthare right so Glenn yunan and it
was even on the ballot like like
abortion wasn't even on the
ballot
but Glenn yin's like hey just elect me
and elect Republicans and I'll take your
rights away and people are like no thank
you I appreciate it but I I'll pass and
then in Ohio in Ohio where where
dwine
dwine we lost we want to try to ignore
it good luck with that and JD bance beat
Tim Ryan in Ohio people are like no [__]
no you're not going to take our rights
away from us what are you talking
about and then they were like well who
we going to blame it on because we can't
blame it on men definitely can't blame
it let's blame it on a woman Gabe
Sanchez they blamed it on a woman look
look there's Gabe sanes I mean is it is
it is it at all uh surprising no no yeah
no but but but I I'll tell you I'll tell
you that um that really honestly I'm not
saying they should blame it on a woman
but Rona McDaniel is [__] delusional
absolutely delusional and it's no wonder
that they can't put a message together
because she does lead the RNC and she's
a [__]
idiot but it ain't got nothing to do
with her being a woman it has to do with
well look I mean when when you've got
you know V ramas Swami blaming Ron
McDaniel it's like okay first off yes
she should take some blame because she
is the head of that party but you also
have to blame Donald Trump which V
ramaswami will never do because he's
there to just copy and
uh and cover
up you know for any of of Trump's
misdeeds or uh missteps or whatever and
say oh well actually it's the Deep State
it's the Democrats it's this and that
it's other people that are coming after
Trump he's totally innocent this is
unfair prosecution uh it's a Witch Hunt
so on and so forth so when you see him
on stage he says oh well the person that
we should be blaming because the
question that was asked was you know how
would you basically critique or uh talk
about Donald Trump's failures and he
goes the real thing we should be talking
about is the party as a whole and how
Rona McDaniel is the head of that party
and when be losing this whole time it's
like yeah but there's also been someone
right there up there you know it feels
it feels like it feels like you could
say she's in charge of the RNC but she
is not in charge of the RNC is what you
can almost say but let's listen to what
she said on Meet the Press on Sunday I'm
sure it's just [__] riving let's
listen this isn't true listen I'm proud
to be a pro-life party but we can we can
win on this message the American people
are where we are and they want Common
Sense limitations they want more access
to to adoption did you see that wait did
you catch it there did you catch what
she almost did now number one the lie
that that this country is on the same
page as Republicans on abortion like hey
hey dude I don't know if you know this
you lost every [__] election
away from your ideals like the opposite
of like not only are people like I don't
believe in what you believe they're like
no you cannot [__] with our government
the way that you believe it but watch
watch when she says what she wants
listen we are yeah and they want Common
Sense limitations they want more access
to to adoption did you see it did you
see it did you see it that they want
more access to watch watch itations they
want more access to to adoption she's
like I mean [__]
it's funny because she's like oh look
the American people are where we are
they want more access to
a adoption it's really [__] funny
like come on come on you're not fooling
anybody we know we know what we know she
knows the [__] right and what I mean by
that is is we know that she knows that
really honestly the American people
don't [__] think the way Republicans
think but let's continue ra they want
more access to to adoption
we want to make sure there's prancy
crisis centers these are things we can
win on but we have to talk about it and
you can't hide in a corner and think
abortion is not going to be an issue
when the [__] haven't they been talking
about abortion like my entire [__]
life okay I wna I want to give you I
want to give you a history lesson here
in my history and you went to the
Catholic Church you were confirmed in a
Catholic Church I'm sure I was baptized
I I I
uh I was I was not an alter boy I was
not an alter boy what I was yeah we
already went over this dude I was
baptized communion and then also uh
confirmation so so you were confirmed in
the Catholic church now in the Catholic
church to to to to get confirmed if
people don't know this out there you
have to go through classes it's
confirmation classes some places have
different names for them but that's I
even had I was in a I went to Catholic
grade school and middle school right and
I still had to take classes I had to do
on on top of normal like theology I had
to take classes to then be confirmed
well you had to do community service you
had to do whole like Research into the
name that you chose and with the names
that you were thinking about and then
you had to look into the history of this
and the history of that now the names
that you're talking about is your
confirmation name because you take a f
fake middle name right right you got a
you got a a second middle name which
isn't actually a real middle name it's
just some stupid thing that you do in
the church now here's the thing is that
the the the craziest part about
this is my entire [__] life now when
I was being confirmed I was in high
school I think it was a sophomore it's
probably 15 or 16 something like that
when I started a confirmation class and
when I started a confirmation class the
the word abortion came up and and we
were all asked if we were pro life or
pro-choice and I said at that time I
said I'm I'm pro-choice because why
wouldn't you let I mean I wouldn't want
someone telling me what the [__] to do
why wouldn't I why would I want I look
if you were to flip the script and and
have the government tell men what to do
right with their then you would have you
know people like speaker micro Johnson
telling you that that is uh against
against the word of God against the word
of the government I mean then again you
do have people like Mar uh Lauren
bobbert who says that it should be the
Bible and the church directing the
government and if that is actually true
then it also blows apart a lot if not
all of their arguments that they have
when you look at the actual teachings of
Christ and how much of a socialist he
was and how caring he was for other
people easy on the truth there with the
mangas okay easy on the truth now here's
the thing though is that I actually left
the Catholic Church before I was
confirmed and the reason why is because
this went on for months and months and
months we had class after class after
class about how I was pro-choice and
they were trying to change my [__]
mind and I told them I said you're not
GNA change my [__] mind just you can
just move on and they wouldn't move on
they kept going so one day I finally
said I'm I'm done I'm not gonna get I
guess I can't be cath like [__] you so I
left and I never went [__] back I
never went back but to think this was
this was in like
1999 okay this wasn't yesterday you man
premillennium yeah well it happens but
Rona McDaniel here thinks that they're
just now oh man this is just now an
issue this abortion thing is just now an
issue like what the [__] are you talking
about you prif you right to life
[__] have been yelling and
screaming about this for decades and
decades and decades you won't shut the
[__] up so much so that you that you
Rigg the game so that you had Supreme
Court Justices that would take away
people's [__] rights in this country
that were enshrined that were that were
good and now that you've taken them away
people are saying you can't take these
[__] rights away if you do we'll
[__] pass referendums in States
because it's about states rights which I
got another clip about Rona MCD and
state rights go ahead yeah I well I was
just going to say I mean that was
exactly the point that I was going to
make is the ability for Republicans to
yell and scream about it's always
State's rights don't tell me the big
brother big government tell me what to
do I'm going to do what I'm going to do
because States rats States rats States
rat States and then when it really comes
down to it when push comes to shove and
they're challenged by with the very very
principle that they have charged and
yelled and whed about in public about
how it's always the state's rights don't
no not big government not federal not
National thing it's a states rights
issue and then when the states actually
do get decide because God forbid the
majority
speaks and says what they actually want
so when the majority of people in a
state say you know what I do not want
you to ban abortion I do want to have
access I want to have the ability to go
to Planned Parenthood for more than just
abortion I want to have the ability to
get resources
supplements uh stiens other things to
help me if I do plan to raise this
child and then when it goes to the
states and they decide on it then the
Republicans I mean look at Ohio right
I'm sure you already talked about this
but if you look at Ohio you have this
Republican party now trying to oh no no
no actually that's not what we meant
when we said states rights we we didn't
actually mean that we want Nationals so
now we're going to try to overturn the
referendum that you the very people by
the people we the people
decided no actually what we're going to
do is we really mean us the minority are
going to speak for the majority and
decide what Tony I I'm crazy it kind of
sounds like fascism um it's it's it's
insane but like these what you have here
is you have a bunch of people who get
butt hurt by the very thing that they
yelled
about well here's another clip of Aruna
McDaniel on State of the Union she did
the rounds this week and the reason why
she did the rounds this week Gabe is
because people like Steve Bannon are
saying that she needs to be ousted um
but here she is commenting on the verman
if she if she gets if she gets
ousted it's gonna go down like Mike
Johnson okay it's not going to play like
they want it's not going to play out oh
my God look at this guy who's so
religious and so right-wing and so
extremist it's going to
backfire it's totally going to be a rake
that they're going to step when they
brought him in I was like this is going
to be a rake step because he has to make
a deal with Democrats and as soon as he
negotiates something with one of them M
will turn on him and they're already
turning on him right now right because
what what happened last week they said
oh you know what actually we have
insufficient evidence to go forward with
an impeachment oh my [__] you know
why you know why you know why you know
why what the insufficient evidence is is
because if they subpoena James and
Hunter Biden they have to subpoena
[__] the guy who is in chair of the
committee and his brother because of the
same stupid [__] thing James comr
traded or or gave money $200,000 the
exact [__] amount uh back and forth
between him and his brother so through a
shell company not just back and forth
it's through a shell company it was more
than just Al loone it was a way to get
around I I actually I actually don't
think that the the transaction that I've
seen from James qan on comr and his
brother I don't think it's actually
illegal I think it's [__] it's no
it's Shady right it's Shady but it's not
illegal there's a reason it's they're
evading tax they're evading tax is what
they're doing it's the same reason that
Donald Trump has 500 through companies
or shell companies that he was using for
the Trump organization that were
revealed when he was found the 17 counts
of fraud or whatever what tax tax fraud
earlier this year or last year uh it's
the same thing it's legal but it's shady
as [__] and even Donald Trump told us on
the debate stage against Hillary Clinton
in 2016 he said I know
that they're [__] Con in all of you
and they know the loopholes because I
use them myself which was like that's a
that's a [__] Flex right there to
tell he was like I don't pay taxes
that's makes me smart and now he [__]
around everyone else does it and it's
like that's okay okay go with it I guess
talk to Ren let me show you this clip of
R MCD responding to the verman comments
and then we'll go to the court case um
there in um in New York but let's listen
to this former president Trump who is
the Far and Away front runner
said in a what was supposed to be a
Veterans Day message quote in honor of
our great veterans on Veterans Day we
pledge to you that we will root out the
Communist Marxist fascist and radical
left thugs that live like Vermin within
the confines of our country and then he
went on I mean verman in a Veterans Day
message I'm not going to talk about
candidates that are in I'm not
GNA you could talk to him about what
he's saying I haven't seen the whole
speech [__] obviously we support our
veterans and we're in a primary right
now the RNC is doing our best to make
we're in a primary right now he wasn't
attacking other Republicans by way I
mean we have to there are certain things
that people need to remember one Donald
Trump called uh military losers and
suckers he also talked about uh the the
now past Senator John McCain and he's
like oh he's a loser because he was
captured as a prisoner
P then you have to remember that this
was revealed during the January 6
hearings where they said oh Donald Trump
signed a
memo to
remove our military from
Afghanistan on November 11th and what is
November 11th Tony well it's Veterans
Day so the the the ability for this guy
to sign a memo to then Evacuate the
military from an area that we've spent
20 years
in on Veterans Day as an insult to just
hand it off to the next guy because
that's he's not my problem it's the next
guy meaning Biden which also alludes to
the fact that he accepted that he lost
because he knew that he
lost
um but the Republican party doesn't care
about the military we see again and
again and again look at Lauren bber
margar Taylor green Matt Gates Ted Cruz
all of these people [__] do not give
two shits about the very people that
they send a tweet and say oh thank
goodness for our our troops and soldiers
we love you for everything you guys do
did you say Ted Cruz I thought you said
Ted Cruz I said Ted Cruz well um a lot
of people's cats hate Ted Cruz actually
honestly a lot of people in Texas their
[__] are allergic to Ted Cruz I'm I'm
just going to say that that they're very
allergic to Ted Cruz and they're even
their cat at T Cruz if you want to get I
don't know just I'm just trying to you
said t Cruz I like
yeah my pussy's allergic to Ted Cruz
maybe who isn't even his even Ted Cruz's
wife Heidi is
allergic okay in the same way that Ben
Shapiro's wife is allergic in the same
way that micro Johnson's wife Kelly is
allergic oh man there is so much stuff D
there's a whole Treasure Trove of stuff
I've just learned recently I'm going to
do a deep dive into a what was that
episode about that Family lot of red
flag Flags going off not that they
weren't already going off before but
there's a lot more that's being revealed
as people kind of pry into their lives
you know well let's check into the
courtroom there in New York and see how
it's going hey look who made another
Cameo organization did not try to have
this conspiracy to defraud Banks and
insurers uh to get special rates on
their properties by inflating those
financial statements now if you remember
Don Jr was on the stand as a States
witness just about two weeks ago and he
distanced look at it she's like yeah got
you [__] himself from being you
know one of the top heads of trump
organization and preparing those
financial statements so when he takes
the stand for the defense fact that the
Trump son so there it is there's Donnie
Jr with the of course Donald Trump I
mean has Donald Trump said anything
today I I mean does he say anything
every day I oh there is something I do
want to point out so on the verman stuff
that I haven't seen a lot of people talk
about yeah which is obviously deep
deeply rooted within
anti-Semitism uh it goes you don't say
you don't yeah it's crazy it's like it's
like this you know it's like it is
existed for a you know a very very long
time and it's uh it's it's really coming
out as of late but one of the things is
if you look at the
history of of anti-Semitism but also of
the Jewish population like if you look
at you know the the I don't think many
if any people have really talked about
this but I remember in high school and
this is this stuck with me all the time
is the scapegoating that happened
between the Jewish community and also
the plague right so you've got the 14th
century you've got plague and you've got
disease and you've got uh you've got the
wells that were poisoned you have the
scapegoating that is done against them
to say like oh actually they're the
people that are spreading this they are
the ones who are giving everyone W this
disease they're the ones who are
spreading the Great Plague when really
it's you know obviously the rats are are
carrying these diseases and spreading it
and you know for various reasons but
that's another thing that when I when I
hear the word vermin it always brings me
back to that aspect of History remember
like learning about and being like Oh
when people like oh they're Vermin
they're this they're this they're this
it takes me back to when they
were completely scapegoated and
ostracized from society to be like oh
it's their fault they're the reason that
everyone else is getting sick right now
uh which is obviously insane because
that's not at all true but now it's just
that term of saying Vermin is so
malicious and so vile and so like so to
hear Donald Trump say that again and
only see a couple media sources call it
out and the most they did was like let's
talk about this what's your what's your
feedback it's like no no no no we should
be calling it out wholeheartedly and
talk about how how uh anti-semitic and
how terrible awful disgusting this type
of language is and we will not we will
not allow that to be normalized but I
haven't really seen that from many media
sources it's just been like oh let's ask
let's get your opinion on it okay all
right and carry on you you want to see
how we handle it here you want to see
how we handle it here let me show you
some Ronda Santa supporters who also
would call the same people that Donald
Trump's calling verman verman let me let
me show you some Rhonda Santa supporters
let
[Applause]
me why are they Tony why are they
wearing
masks well so so you can't identify them
because they showed up as one guy one
guy showed up without a mask okay
okay it's wild you know I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
Irish was this from this weekend no this
is a this is just footage of Rhonda
Santa supporter The Shard got it okay
okay this is The Shard Army this is The
Shard Army yeah yeah yeah I didn't know
if that was recent or not I just know
that they they have this weird
infatuation with uh overpasses they love
to hang out on the overpass right and
spread their anti-Semitism and fascism
as people are driving by uh when really
when we look at the opposite right the
people in the cars that are recording
are laughing at them and making fun of
them because they're complete [__]
idiots um but these are the people that
are you know these are the people
supporting Ronda Santos these are the
people this is The Shard
[Music]
Army sh in the sh Army this is your this
is your army Chez this is who you're
supporting these are these are
I mean these are like they love Ronda
Sanz let it sink
[Music]
in these are the people who support
Donald Trump calling people Vermin you
know what's kind of
crazy go ahead for a group of people who
always love to say oh get over it just
move on why don't you just [__] drop
it stop [__] stop [__]
uh talking about it just just move
on they continue to yell out the name of
someone who was
dead but also died a coward in a
bunker uh and also I mean big time loser
big [__] time loser uh but they love
to yell out the name of a guy who no
longer exists was a loser and was a
[__] that H HD in a bunker just like
Donald Trump by the way they love to
scream out his name like oh this guy was
so successful well if he was successful
then why isn't you know why why didn't
he win World War II right why was why
did he die alone pretty much in a bunker
why did he uh hide why was he such a
cuck why was he such a coward you yell
at the name of a guy who was a big
[__] time like big time like World
War loser okay but they love to yell out
his name and go oh Hitler Hitler we love
Hitler well the guy's dead he's a loser
and also like the person that you want
to emulate and you want to support is no
longer
around and democracy and anti-fascists
were able to destroy him and now you're
trying to like do a sance we like Hitler
Hitler Hitler if we say three times
he'll
appear it's weird stuff Shaz says we
condemn Nazis who's we and what Nazis
are you condemning because these Nazis
are standing on this silp pass want
Ronda santis to be uh the governor of
Florida and want want him to be the
president just like you Shaz when you go
policy Point by policy Point you're a
Nazi dummy you're a Nazi dummy that's
that's what that's what I'm trying to
tell you Shaz well Shaz is probably
gonna tell you the Nazis are the
anti-fascists he antifa are the Nazis
they're not the no the Nazis aren't okay
the real fascists or the anti-fascists
we're anti- anti-fascists which don't
make us fascist because we're anti anti
the fascist so dude it's like you
wouldn't even understand because like
chest dude you can't even understand the
equations that I'm doing in my head
right now okay 2 plus 2 equals 17 Q love
it magga Donald Trump
okay well here's another one of shaz's
and The Shard Army's favorite Cary Lake
and here's Tim Miller dunking her in the
[__] trash duning her in the [__]
trash watch this solid two minutes this
is how you [__] handle these [__]
I'm not okay with that I want you to be
able to talk whatever you guys say on
the circus I want to be able to have
conservative students not being shamed
on our golden age for conservative
student speech it's like it's the best
time ever if you're a conservative
student you want to talk you have huge
platforms turning i' I went to watch you
speak at Turning Point USA all these
kids have huge audiences that come to
see them and that's great that's fine
they're all speaking they're not there
be just another threat there weren't any
cops coming to shut down the Turning
Point USA thing but here here's the
thing you care you say you care about
the fentanyl crisis and our kids I deep
care deeply so if you care so deeply
about this couldn't you couldn't you
actually do something about it if you
stopped the [__] about the last
election if you had just acknowledged
that that Trump had lost and
acknowledged that you would lost you'd
probably you might You' probably be in
good shape to do something you probably
would have won your governor's race had
you you had you just talked about things
people cared about instead of the
election fraud so sometimes don't you
ever think to yourself I wish I could
just stop talking about this fake thing
that Donald Trump made me make up so
that I could actually talk about the
stuff that's important because we agree
about Sentinel I agree I wish we could
deal with that I talked about that all
the time of the campaign TR I'm sorry
you weren't with me I'm sorry you
weren't with me every step of the way
the people of Arizona understand me and
they know me and they care about me and
I care about
them that's one of the best moments
she's like they know me they understand
me frankly I feel like I think Arizona
knows exact who I am and they would put
me in my place if I needed to be and
he's like they rejected you like they
they they told you to [__] off like they
know who you are they and and it goes it
actually goes to so there's this there's
a what was that that I'm I'm I'm uh
wrapping up writing I'm gon to film
later today which is on Jonathan Carl
who's the ABC News host and he's got a
book coming out that's about Donald
Trump and like the demise of the G or
like the destruction of the
GOP and in there he reveals some tapes
that in conversations he had with Donald
Trump and with others like Mo Brooks and
others and there's this whole idea
because back in 2021 I don't know if
people remember this there's a whole
timeline that I just happened to
remember and I was like oh this is great
because I'm going to bring it up in this
episode where all the conspiracies that
people had about when Donald Trump was
going to be reinstated in 2021 there was
uh it was going to happen on January
20th and then it was September 89th
September 89th
was it was going to happen January 20th
March 4th March 20th April
30th uh there's there's another date in
there as well and then August q and's a
hell of a drug by the way it's crazy and
remember some of these dates are Mike
Lindell some of these dates are queueing
on and a lot of this is just like the
lack of comprehension and reading from
people that all of a sudden became
overnight constitutional experts same
people same people who were like I know
exactly about epidemiology it's like
[__] you didn't even [__] high
school biology okay shut up shut up shut
up shut up so these are the people that
are pushing this idea and it completely
goes to this point that Miller is trying
to make against Carri Lake which is like
you might have possibly been successful
with more people if you wouldn't have
dragged on this idea that it was a
rigged election because it wasn't there
has been every court case that has been
fought has been lost there is defamation
lawsuits against Mikael Lindell Sydney
Powell Fox News between Dominion
smartmatic you have to realize that it
is a losing battle and a losing
narrative to try to say oh it was rigged
it was rigged it was rigged well dude
you're you're two years too late now you
got to get over almost three years at
this point you got to get over it you
have to move on and again goes back to
the point of these people don't know how
to move on despite the fact that they
say oh just [__] get over move on
stop stop really bitching about it that
these are the very people who are unable
to let go when they
lose well I'm gonna say don't let go of
Gab Sanchez is what was it go subscribe
to gab's YouTube channel youtube.com gab
Sanchez or go to IAB sanchez. comom you
will follow him everywhere there don't
miss a single what was that or a what
was that live tomorrow Wednesday and
Thursday every single week right after
this show not today but Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday one hour what was
that live with the guy with the last
name Sanchez and I also want to thank
everyone over the weekend for purchasing
more of the this machine kills fashion
the tattoo merch and also the even my
dog hates Ted Cruz Merch this is a
really popular one and I believe I
believe that um the cat merch is going
to be successful as well even my cat
hates Ted Cruz so go get them now go to
the Tony michaels.com also visit while
you're on the Tony michaels.com click
the book club link that's right we got a
book club going on over on Discord the
library of democracy and pay attention
to the library of democracy the mighty
librarian is gonna have a lot of project
2025 stuff and the community should get
behind the library of democracy and help
with this project 2025 stuff to get the
word out there now that this now that
this election's over this next election
is going to be about stomping out
Fascism and there's nothing more fascist
that the Republican and Heritage
Foundation are getting behind in Project
2025 so go to the Tony michaels.com join
the book club and also follow the
library of democracy YouTube channel as
well Gabe Sanchez I'm glad you joined us
I'm glad you were here on this Monday
audience to make fun of Shaz in The
Shard Army he's the first someone
pointed out he's the first
Troll he's the first
troll that got a theme song thanks to
him the Nazis The Shard Army Trump and
his his beloved guy in high heels
a lot of people a lot of people are
wondering if Shaz is really fake Gabe
reincarnated could be could be could be
we'll get to the bottom of it tomorrow
here on the Tony Michels podcast same
time same place surf sub
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podcast in
your face commentary of current events
in political news no rules No Boundaries
I think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you you enjoyed the show and
we'll be back soon in the meantime
follow Tony on social media at the Tony
Michaels and until next time raise a
fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass speaking
K go
more
[Music]
all
[Applause]
see all
[Music]
Lord
see